So great, we've found a factor. How does this help us though? Eventually I want
to get f of x in it's fully factored form, but what do we do with this single
factor that we already know to find out the other factors? Well, let's think.
If we have a number like 12 and we know that two is a factor of it. Then if we
divide 12 by 2 we get 6.As what we need to multiply by two to get twelve. So
that means that all of the other factors must multiply to equal six. Then we
can also factor six in to two and three. Those are the other two prime factors
of 12. So now we have the full prime factorization of 12. It's just equal to 2
times 2 times 3. So looks like if we divide a number by a factor that's known,
then we get a simplified number in this case, or expression in this case that
is a product of the leftover factors we're still looking for. That means that
we shoudl divide this expression by x minus 2. To get one step closer to
figuring out our other factors. But how do we do this. Well, you'll have to
wait for the next lesson to find out.